o'clock in which case we can get the
meeting underway I'd like to welcome
everybody to today's meeting of the
panel both those that participating and
those who are watching from home if you
have any technical difficulties during
the meeting then please contact the
Democratic services officer on call who
will attempt to assist you
today's officer on call is Charlotte
Crowley and the number to call is five
double seven one nine three what would
ask participants when you are not
speaking please mute your microphone
this minimizes background noise and will
help everyone in listening to the
proceedings microphones must only be on
if the participant has been granted
permission to speak the game my
permission to speak please very briefly
indicate on the chat to the right side
of the screen and I will then make a
note and go back to you once the person
speaking is finished and if I forget I'm
sure Charles will remind me would
everyone present please ensure that
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls whilst the meeting
is in progress please also refrain from
checking emails or conducting other
business and ensure that you're in the
quiet room free from distractions for
the duration of the meeting please note
that this meeting is being live-streamed
for members of the public the meeting
will also be recorded and will
subsequently be broadcast on the
Internet
please can I ask the members of the
panel to confirm that they are present
in the meeting when I read out your name
I will ask for the attendance of those
counselors who are participating under
in order to speak under 20.1 separately
so members if you could acknowledge that
your here counts the Campbell yes I'm
here but councillor Boyd castor Coleman
cook yes here counts the Hopkinson
counter Hopkinson no counselor Huxley
can stop concern you're now here yes yes
yeah sergeant okay counselor Huxley yes
I'm here
counselor keen yes here counselor patent
law counselor patent law
no counselor Palmer Cass the pull more
now counsel ended white not casalinda
Piper counselor Ratigan yeah I'm here
counselor Piper okay thank you Tony
Linda okay catch the Ratigan counselor
wing yes I'm here
okay counselor is a key I've seen but
can you confirm your hair still I'm here
still Bob thank you excellent thank you
and counts the Scotch present chair
thank you right the following members
have asked to speak under counsel
procedural 20.1 when I say your name
please can you confirm that you are
present at the meeting counselor Ashby
I'm here Council of Ghana I'm here pop
and counts the Dexter I'm here Bob
okay are there any more members who
would like to speak under 20.1 no thank
you
with today we do not have any requests
for public speaking moving on apologies
for absence councillor Roper who
substituted by counsel of wing are there
any more apologies sorry say that
counselor Pat Moore is being assisted to
get into the meeting by shot at the
moment so she's fully intends to join us
she hasn't given her apologies okay
thank you Nick thank you
okay are there any declarations of
interest
okay agenda item three minutes of
previous meeting to approve the meeting
of the overview to approve February 20
20 copies of jet was attached to the
agenda pack
can I have a proposer please answer the
Campbell proposes thank you can have a
seconder I'll second that
so thank you very much thank you cats
comm cook unless I hear any objection I
will take these as approved I can
members those are approved thank you
very much we move on to pre decision
scrutiny agenda item 4 I'd just like to
make a few comments to put this agenda
item into context before we begin the
report by the independent inspectors
concludes that the draft local plan is
sound but only if all of the inspectors
modifications are accepted and x2 of the
panel report this is because the
modifications are considered by the
inspectors to be necessary to make the
plan sound legally compliant and capable
of adoption the decision for the council
is therefore to either adopt the draft
plan with the modifications in the
inspectors report or to not adopt the
plan it is not open to the council
either to partially accept the
modifications or to make further changes
to the plan that go beyond the
inspectors report and have not been
recommended by the inspectors this would
leave the council with a local plan that
was not sound the plan report and the
briefing notes sets out the significant
risk risk for the council of not having
a local plan in place I would therefore
ask members to bear this in mind when
raising points about the inspectors
report or the panel report the role of
the panel tonight is therefore to
consider the inspectors report and the
main modifications and to agree any
recommendations for cabinet to consider
prior to it making its final
recommendations to Council the
recommendations should therefore be
changed to reflect the revolts to
reflect the role of the RNs panel
deceive me the revised recommendation is
as follows the overview and scrutiny
panel
recommended to consider the main
modification from the inspectors report
and agree what representations if any to
make the cabinet the cabinet to consider
prior to making its final
recommendations to Council
is that clear members okay moving on I
will now introduce Adrian Farrell to
introduce the report thank you variant
Thank You chair good evening members I'm
going to keep my introduction brief as
you already have the report and a
briefing made I'm very pleased that
we've finally received our inspectors
report on the local plan it seems to
have taken a long time I'm also very
pleased that they found the plans sound
subject to the modifications and that's
all set out in annex 2 of the report the
key pada fication to set out a paragraph
2.8 of the panel report as you will see
from the report much of the local plan
strategy is supported by the inspectors
overall healthy numbers and science
employment land insight policy relating
to retail and tourism and a range of
environmental policies as well it's
important to have an adopted local plan
in place with the adoption of the plan
the council have a strong planning
policy framework which gives the council
greater control over the development
process it provides certainty for local
people about the scale of and location
of development and also supports the
work of the planning applications team
particularly in terms of dealing with
the pebbles it also means that the
planning applications team can rely on
the plan in dealing with the larger
housing sites and in seeking to ensure
all the infrastructure open space and
other facilities are provided in a
timely manner it would also support the
council in making bids for government
funding for infrastructure improvements
without a sound plan there is a risk of
further intervention or direction by the
Secretary of State it would place the
Council of risk in terms of Appeal
decisions and potentially could
jeopardize the delivery
infrastructure or government funding
essentially it risks the council losing
control of the development process this
detailed advice on this stage of the
local plan is is in an Apollo report
under Section two and I would support
the Chairman's earlier comments about
how to consider the inspectors main
modifications I'm happy to answer any
questions members may have Thank You Jen
Thank You Adrian what I intend to do is
to take the members who are speaking
under 20.1 get them to make their
representations to the panel and then
Adrian come back to you for comment on
that then we move on to the panel
members and the discussion there so a
councillor Ashby Thank You chair and
yeah I would just like to ask a question
which I submitted earlier so hopefully
it's um Adrian received that okay under
the draft Local Plan Policy SP 23 4.36
States there are various green
infrastructure projects being Pro
progressed by the council and other
organizations and also a number of
community projects Thames Valley Woods
is listed under this section within the
dlp this site was also included in the
Thanet Local Plan 2006 under SR 14
community woodlands which stated support
will be given to the establishment of a
newly of a new publicly accessible
woodland of an appropriate scow in
suitable locations in the district
notably at the urban fringe for
recreation landscape and nature
conservation purposes the following
sites are currently proposed for
community woodlands one hearts bound
twenties Margate and Bayne Valley Road
Margate my question is is it true to say
that there is no provision in the new
plan for any new woodland area despite
the specific reference to the 25-year
environmental plan 2018 in the
modifications also is there a mechanism
to carry over any unfulfilled statements
made in the tooth
thousand and six local plan for the Dane
rally site and if so how would it be
action thank you
Thank You counselor I should be
counselor garner thank you
yeah I just like to raise a point really
which which is partly a question I know
that the inspector has identified a
number of areas to be considered in the
six-month review which was kicked off
last week and when I'm part of the local
plan review group one of the main areas
that the inspector identified was
climate change so it does sort of link
in with council I should be just just
said I just want to make sure that as
part of this six-month review the
climate change working group which will
be working in parallel to the local plan
group can sync up together so because
I'm sure there will be a number of
changes identified and recommended by
the climate change working group that
will need to invite to the local plan
and I want to make sure that those
changes they took the climate change
working group doesn't drag too long so
as we missed they missed the boat to
enable the changes to be made to the to
the local plan as part of the local plan
with you just want to make sure that
that there that synced up and it is sort
of recorded to make sure it all links up
together thank you thank you so go on
accounts the dead star yeah Thank You
mr. chairman I have nothing to say at
this point but I may come out I've just
come here to observe but I may like to
say something later thank you very much
councillor Dexter I don't you can't make
a comment later if you come in under 20
point one you need to speak now and then
unfortunately you have to observe the
rest of the meeting okay it's a savage
can can confirm that roses rules no
that's all right
I unders there you go yeah
thank you thank you
okay mr. Verrill would you like to
comment on the the two points made so
far please mr. barrel I used to pull you
there obviously not Thank You chairman
my mute button
just kept disappearing again oh that
knot that line again you use that this
morning yes yes so um the questions
raised by counsel Ashby yes it's it's
right to say that there aren't any
specific sites identified for new
woodland planting in the draft local
plan the word to science so she rightly
says in the 2006 plan they were based on
a couple of projects that the council
was working on at that time
there aren't any new ones currently
being proposed at the moment and that's
why there's nothing in the current local
plan but obviously if projects do
develop over the next few months this is
something that we could pick up in the
local plan review there is quite a lot I
won't go through in detail this quite a
lot in that in a local plan about new
open space particularly on the strategic
sites some of which is likely to be
landscaping woodland and there are a
number of other policies supporting the
provision of grieving and infrastructure
on new sites and in relation to the
second question
there's not really a mechanism for us to
carry that forward the data so that the
reference the Dane Valley would in this
plan but the site is protected as local
green space as part of the local plan
and as the site is currently used as
open space in woodland
that's sufficient to protect the site
for that purpose for future years so
that's the situation we're in but we
can't make a late change to the plan in
respect to the day in Valley woods
then the other question was from
councillor garner relating to climate
change yeah there are council officers
involved in an officer working group and
we are trying to pick up the issues that
come out of a climate change working
group the end of the six mark that's
just to Sarila mean that we can't look
at other changes during the update
period the review period just enables us
to identify some of the key issues that
are emerging so I hope the two things
will work in parallel together thank you
okay I should be even because you'd like
to come back that I mean that that's not
usual but is it a quick point you want
to make oh yes please chair and it's
just for Adrian and the reason I asked
for about the unfulfilled Stone Thames
Valley sigh it was the fact that that
could also that could be deemed to be
reincarnated if you like for a new site
obviously it can if it could come in
under the under the consultation period
and be shown as an amendment that's the
reason I brought it in was the fact that
nothing has really happened to it and it
hasn't fulfilled what it was originally
intended in 2006 so what I'm basically
saying he's could that come back in is a
reinstatement and be providing a
woodland site for a new technically a
new wooden site because it wasn't it
wasn't fulfilled the last time around
mr. Barrow
it's too late to make that change at
this stage of the plan really
he's something we can pick up in the
review and there's no reason why that
shouldn't be looked at as I say he's
protected his local green space so the
site as a site is protected for the long
term in any event so it's something we
could look at as part of the review
thank you
Thank You members moving on now to panel
members have counts the Pam ball who
would like to make some points oh yeah
thank you
thank you both first of all just like to
congratulate
it's a Adrian on an enormous amount of
work this is as you and I know Bob this
local plan has been in various
incarnations been going on for about 11
years I mean I was it obvious of me oh
boy when first class nothing and I'm
certainly not that now although my group
is not particularly support all the
recommendations within the local plan
we're prepared to propose acceptance
Academy acceptance of the draft local
plan with the amendments by the
inspector to go through to ensure that
this council has a sustained local plan
otherwise this council is extremely
vulnerable thank you thank house the
Campbell Council is a key Thank You
chair now just a quick comment as
councillor Campbell's just said yeah
congratulations on getting this far I'd
like to thank the other independents
we're just helping out to get this far
and we shall be supporting the promoting
this local plan and let's move it
forward and get this council safe so
thank you guys for uzuki
are there any other comments from
members back at Hopkinton councillor
Hopkinson just done' I'll meet myself
sorry okay you've succeeded yeah thank
you
and I mean I'm not sure you know I'm
just trying to understand the the exact
implications of you know the fact we
have to accept modifications as they are
I mean am i Ryan understanding I mean
I'll be able to pick up on specific bits
of wording and and particular issues
during this meeting and ask cabinet to
consider those or do we have to just
because I have a series of things I
would like to suggest or consider the
cabinet consider but I'm not unclear if
if we're actually our way I mean are we
able to do that during this
I'll be able to suggest the most
particular things well as far as that I
understand it what we can do tonight is
to make comments and that would include
your thoughts on perhaps how things
could be improved but if you make those
points then we can ask mr. Verrill if
any of those are sort of ruled out of
course obviously some things would be
unacceptable but if if you'd like to go
ahead and make your points then we can
take it on from there Cass Hopkinson
okay thanks yeah I mean couple of them
are quite minor things like Inception
2.30 which lists the sort you know all
the major overall points for for
strategy towards Ramsgate
releasing the merino and things that it
doesn't actually less rounds gate ports
and although that's the minor thing it
seems to me you know symbolically it's
important to to stay in that pretty
important paragraph that the port is
considered part of the council's
approach you know particularly given the
public consultation and the the
consideration we're all putting in to
what could happen to the poor that's one
point I had about the port at 2.30 and
it related to that at one point in the
report does say that the the council
ideally want to have a roll-on/roll-off
service around gate port but I would
have thought that's not really accurate
at the moment and so I wonder if that's
something that we could ask cabinet to
consider Cheney given that you know my
understanding is that we're currently
open-minded as to what the poor could be
so it's misleading to say that we as far
as I understand it's misleading to say
that we want it to be a role and role of
service there okay by your comment at
Hawkinson I have got some others but I
just you know perhaps they can be some
Knights make all your points and then we
can get them dealt with
okay so I was contacted only within the
this afternoon or thing and I've
imaginary all other members were
contacted as well by westward town
council by email and they they make the
point that the population projections
which lots of this document is based on
will put together in 2014 and they claim
that they are inaccurate and that we
could do better in terms of projections
now I don't have any idea really whether
they are correct about that because we
only just received this afternoon and I
can't comment on that but I wonder if we
could put it to to cabinet to consider
the West Gate Town Council's proposal
that we look at updating those
projections to something more reliable
which is what they proposed so that's
and other points I wanted to make before
you carry them before you as I
understand it and mr. Verrill can
confirm or deny this in a minute the
housing numbers at this particular point
I don't think are subject to any kind of
change they were worked out to a formula
and the inspectors having job does that
number although they changed the the
timing if you like of the housing
delivery so I don't think that will be
on but mr. Verrill will still come back
to that in a minute I think did you want
to reiterate the point that we hear are
not really in the position of changing
the local plan that's not really an
option but there will obviously be a
time when we come to the six months
reviewed for people to put that point of
view across so if you want to move on to
your next point counselor Hopkinson yeah
it's I wonder if the the plan is taking
full account of some other things in the
counselors decided state forward for
example in the the corporate statement
you know we've committed to something
I've got a personal interest in which is
the community wealth building program
and I wonder if you know part more
anything else if that shouldn't get a
mention within the document and there's
for example a suggestion about where
that could go and I think is 1.24
would be you know a very easy place to
just add in reference to that as part of
the overall strategy towards growth and
creation of opportunities and Thanet so
it seems to me that would be an easy
place to put that in and it seems to me
also that it you know it's a bit of an
omission
if community wealth building isn't
mentioned in the local clan given that
it's on the corporate statement and it's
already an agreed objective of the
council as I understand it okay I you
know this is a wider point coming out of
that is that you know this may well be
something which can't be changed at this
point but it if the community wealth
building is mentioned and is part of the
plans then it could have a bearing on
some of the things that I mentioned in
the document and it might have an effect
on how some of those things are worded
and frames but you know that's what was
asked in the beginning I'm not sure if
it's possible for us to consider that I
think okay thank you
councillor wing master wing sorry I've
tried to find my mute button yes I'm
standing in for Trevor so I'm probably
playing a bit of catch-up but one of the
song time coming the local plan so thank
you to everybody who's put it together
but I'm assuming that the document is
flexible and would move and change and I
think the local plan was delivered pre
Covey's and now we've got this post
Kovach situation arising where normal
the normal we know probably isn't going
to exist again so I suppose my first
comment is what will we do with the
local plan has the new normal emerges
because we've got no idea what the new
normal is going to look like until a
cure is found and the other question is
I suspect wherever we said we support
the airport or not we continue to be
frustrated by a decision over Manston
how will that delay in that decision
again
possibly affect the local plan so
they're just to two points to be mindful
of thank you thank you then councillor
Scott yeah right yeah I feel like I
should just there chime in with my two
cents as well I mean first of all I
understand that the local plan is there
a very contentious subject and there's
also a lot a lot of work has gone into
it and it's Leon the grander scheme of
things and however I do feel like I need
to have my sort of say my Ward's
specifically but overall I mean on sort
of that cultural land one of the key
aspects is we're gonna potentially lose
a lot of grade one agricultural land
which is obviously not ideal in the
slightest it's not reversible I mean
once it's built upon we have now lost
that fundamental lands which we can at
this time grow and harvest crops on and
I think the biggest concern for me is
obviously we've we've now been sort of
given a bit of a lifeline where
apparently for for us the West Gate that
this is going to be the building's gonna
be put back a bit further but during
that time should things change such as
any sort of end current climate and
landscape would we continue to actually
look for ground field sites I mean if we
are able I am a preacher and understand
that the the house numbers cannot be
changed now but we are able to actually
found find legitimate and accommodate in
brownfield sites can be potentially
shift and protect what is essentially
our green fields so I mean that's just a
comment that I feel is certainly on a
non-speaking possibly for myself but
maybe a number of the villages probably
feel that sentiment so thank you Thank
You councillor Scott mr. Verrill I think
there's one or two points for you to
address there thank you Jim not try and
pick those up if you forget any will
remind you don't worry I thank you I
think in all honesty most of these
points are points that we could pick up
in the review it's too late to deal with
those through this
process just to cover a couple of quick
things that were mentioned certainly
there was a discussion at the
examination about the role of the port
there were people objecting to if being
a port and there was a discussion about
whether we ought to change that policy
our view at the time that point there
was no consort consultants study in
relation to possible future options was
that the policy should remain as it is
for the time being and that we would
pick this up in the review so I
understand the Bloods are being made
about port Ramsgate I'm aware of the
study I have recently regular
conversations with Mike Humber and
others who are involved in that and we
would pick up up in the review and
similarly with the other points
community wealth building certainly the
resilience issue that was raised by
councilor wing in some particular in
terms of Kobe but you could apply that
across a wide variety of topics about
how we plan for resilience in the future
and I think that probably will change
the way we apply certain things I note
the point about the airport that is a
matter for the review and obviously
we'll need to look at whatever decision
comes out and making decisions
accordingly so clearly if the airport
DCO is granted we'll need to look at
things like traffic impacts public
safety zones air quality aircraft noise
contours all those sorts of things that
are sort of knock-on from that if it's
not then at some point not to gonna be
sure when but we will need to look at
what happens to the site if it's not
going to be used for aviation I know the
point that was made about agricultural
land but we have to find sites for
housing that's not really an option
available to us to not find sites there
are are lots of brownfield sites in the
local plan we released a
30 hectares of older industrial land
housing but I think we still have you
know we still had to fire find the the
sites for those other housing units and
the inspectors have supported the sites
that we've proposed and said that that's
a sound approach the strategic sites
only take about five percent of the
agricultural land in San in this in this
plan but obviously in the review we will
look again at whatever brownfield sites
become available during that time and
include those I think the earth of point
related to population projections I yes
the the government the pop the
population projections at least every
two years so 14 16 and 18 but they don't
come through as housing projections
until later but the government when the
2016 projections were published advise
local authorities that they should stick
with the 2014 projections because they
didn't consider the 2016 projections to
be sufficiently accurate which is why we
were working to those at the moment I
hope I've answered all the questions but
come back if I have any thank you one
thing I don't think you've addressed
Adrian was councilor wings point that
you know given covert and so on that you
know the world might never be the same
again and this plan was written
obviously a snapshot in time before that
question is how is the local plan
treated in that changed world and how do
we go about modifying it or you know how
do we respond to the reality that we
find against that kind of mythical world
that the local plan paints
oh well I think largely it would have to
be a matter for the review we still have
to find sufficient hours in sites to me
I'll need the design of those individual
sites may change so when applications
are being prepared it may be the the way
they approach say public spaces or help
people access housing that the way that
that design may change to some degree to
respond to that resilience issue there
is some guidance that's been produced by
the local government information union
which we will be looking at as part of
the review process I think with when it
comes to applications on the allocated
sites that's gonna have to be looked at
on a site by site basis by the
individual case officers and and
Planning Committee as they come through
I hope thank you it's a bit uncertain
with yeah how we respond to this at the
moment okay and the other one that
sticks in my mind is this question that
the local plan refers to a RORO ferry at
the polls but that isn't necessarily
what we might be wanting if you could
explain that a bit yeah as I say ad
there was a discussion about this at the
examination and the deport policy that
exists at the moment is not dissimilar
to what was in previous plans we were
aware that some consultants were going
on looking at potential future options
of the port but at the time that hadn't
been published or no decisions had come
out of that so our position with the
inspectors was that we felt the policy
should remain as it is until those
decisions are made and obviously that's
an ongoing process and we will try and
pick up the changes to the port strategy
through the review of the plan so that
it's more closely related to whatever
decision comes out of that process thank
you accounts the Boyd and I'll talk
about the review of the plan he can
clarify with me and if
review the plans has been six months or
was it within six months if so could we
bring it forward or it risk that if we
leave it six months that those designer
housing people whether you want to call
them that are ready and willing to
submit their application now because
they've been on it for twenty months
plus how do we know that they could
submit their plan application before we
get to review and therefore these
elements that we want to change we can't
mr. Gura yeah the the client for us to
review the plan that's that's an
internal process so that's for the
council to review what's in the this
plan once is adopted and to say what
needs to change how we update the plan
so and that's six months has been
effectively set by the Secretary of
State and also by our inspectors so yes
it is likely that planning applications
for some of those sites will come
forward in that process in that
timescale and we all have to consider
them against the plan thank you members
do I have any other speakers on this
item okay um we talked at the beginning
about how we were going to handle this
and they said that we would take all
comments and areas that have been raised
by members and and include them in a
list to send the cabinet but I'm also
minded that at the beginning counts the
Campbell raised the point that you know
the necessity for us to have this
adopted plan subject to being reviewed
in six months and he was suggesting a
recommendation to cabinet that subject
to note in the comments that have been
made overview and scrutiny are
recommending that the plan and the
inspectors amendment
be removed be passed
does that find a seconder anywhere I'll
second that chair thank you thank you in
terms of taking a vote once again as I
did at beginning if I will take silences
acquiescence so our members happy for
that to go forward so it's a
recommendation to adopt that the plan
and the member and the inspectors
suggested changes having taken note of
the comments that members have made
tonight which I will ask Charles to
include in the recommendation going on
to cabinet I don't hear again sorry
because I don't yet I mean is it
possible if I were to abstain you can
abstain yeah if that's what you want to
do okay okay so with one extension that
is passed members thank you moving on
agenda item five post decision scrutiny
there are no items under this section
tonight and moving on to Section six
review of the Obion scrutiny panel work
program 2019 to 2020 members are asked
to note the report does anyone have any
comment I want to make on that okay no
it is like Pradhan Cass Campbell no no
thank you
would you care to note agenda item seven
as well with the four would plan an
exempt cabinet report which were that
it's got two items on it yes I certainly
will
no thank you once again members if I
don't hear any cries of anguish thank a
time six and seven this having been
agreed your silence is golden
can I thank you members
for your participation this evening
Thank You officers for the support and
wish you all a very good evening thank
you